I'm less than 24 hours after hundreds of
migrants were seen sleeping on a New
York City sidewalk they were suddenly
gone yesterday afternoon City officials
not offering details on exactly what
happened to them it comes as the city
struggles to find housing for the flood
of Asylum Seekers pouring into the city
with us now Joe Borelli New York City
Council minority leader Joe it's always
great to have you on I mean where'd they
go right there the city is saying well
they went to an interim place and the
only place we really know where about
110 of these went people went is to a
church on Long Island that's a lot of
unaccounted people Joe what's going on
yeah Beyond sleeping in the church
basement I don't really have any idea
look let me be clear though I'm glad
they're they're not camping out in front
of the hotel we have to be more
proactive in front of all of these
migrant shelters where this type of
behavior is happening but to be clear
Trace we've leased over 100 hotels for
this purpose we have a population of
migrants right now larger than the
population of Helena Montana who we are
paying for their room their board their
health care their education everything
this is an unsustainable situation and
it really is only evidenced by the fact
that these people are sleeping on the
streets because they just won't stop
coming yeah Eric Adams was pleading with
the byte Administration I'm going to
show some of that sound and we'll get
your response in the other side watch
there is no more room we have not got
money
um you know out of the 850 million
dollars that Senator Schumer and uh
leader Jeffrey was able to push through
uh we uh we got 30 million
30 million
and uh there were bordering states that
received more money than us and they're
using the money to bus people to New
York well Kirsten Cinema is going to
push back on that in a second I'll I'll
hold that for a minute but but the mayor
also said that he will not have tents on
every street but this is a guy who
rolled out the Welcome Wagon right he
said come on in bragged about the fact
they were a sanctuary City and now he's
like the sanctuary City status is is
just unattainable
yeah I I think their first thought was
maybe there'd be five thousand people
ten thousand people maybe it'd be a cute
experiment to show how Progressive we
are but now unfortunately he's not wrong
there is literally no more room at the
end and New York taxpayers can't uh bear
this brunt any Lawler Trace we're paying
more than the entire budget of the fire
department and the sanitation department
uh right now every single day to pay for
this crisis uh we we simply can't afford
it and unfortunately the federal
government has not been a partner if
anything they have been an adversary on
this because they were the ones who
originally started flying migrants and
bussing them to these states it wasn't
Greg Abbott it wasn't other Governors it
was the Federal Government who started
this process it was the Federal
Government who opened the borders and
that's the point and Kirsten Cinema said
the following the reason the money and
she's saying you know they're not
getting any money in the border states
the reason the money is going to New
York is because the speaker of the house
is from New York and the leader of the
U.S Senate is from New York the fact
that the money goes to New York City is
wrong because they are not border states
and they are not facing the kind of
pressure we are and New York and Eric
Adams and none of these other states
said a word when these migrants were
flooding Arizona and Texas which they
still are and nobody said a word until
they came their way your final thoughts
on this Joe
but I I empathize with people in the
border states but now our whole country
is a border state because of the failure
of Joe Biden period full stop we had a
president who made this issue a priority
and things were much better not perfect
but much better and we need to go back
to a policy uh the policies of the Trump
Administration yeah and they keep
talking about oh we need immigration
reform immigration reform would change
the immigration system it would not stop
people from coming across the border
because even with immigration reform you
can only let in so many Joe Borelli
always great to have you on thank you
I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and
I'm Ainsley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis